tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj g mi è mancato la funzione di
brutto ma una cupola michael jackson
stiamo sud roma i ragazzi erano un
secolo erano tre mesi che non lo faccio
ogni volta che faccio in episodi di sta
roba poi possono essere cacciarli prima
che io lo rifaccia cominciava ragazzi
perché fa vj mangia mangia i bambini si
2 plan for fun igiene ragazzi i nomi
delle parti ti sto gioco sono la cosa
più bella di tutte ma vj's boutique
ma cosa se continuo così muoio di
crepacuore buongiorno a voi già tu sei
brutto preparò il culo a tutti quando ma
questo è sicuro perché sono sono già
pronto all'attacco d'altro siamo inizia
inizio io fisherman fisherman's ufficio
ha già un ok dai perciò posso fare avevo
abbandonato questo gioco una volta per
un motivo ed edera questo già in un
design questo schifo secondo me una
persona normale non indovinerebbe mai
una cagata così però dovrebbe essere
fish andai non è difficile cazzo
ecco ti ho fatto anche voi che faccia
già aveva 33 chiappelli perché
ovviamente tutti pescatori ragazzi hanno
tre capelli 3 mi chiama nessuno ha
indovinato
ma siete [ __ ] cazzo fisher marmi che
glielo si legge in faccia che un
fisherman no non sapete indovinare le
cose se fate schifo ragazzino indovino
subito scelto riolo a caso ha già in
inglese inglese cetrioli certo io no io
faccio pagare ad insegnarmi come lo so
mi chiama fa proprio schifo tuo amico e
tua nonna giamaica ma che nessuno
scritto già mangia manica burrito
burrito e perché questa roba dovrebbe
mai somigliare ad un burrito io io
faccio veramente cagare a questo gioco
ma gesù santos è gente che veramente
dovrebbe sarà arrestata per come disegno
cioè non è colpa mia
giusy al world fiat fiat fiat disegniamo
la paura come si può rappresentare la
paura rega
credo che sia ecco perche fermi che mi
faccia un autoritratto vediamo che
funziona devono conoscermi devono
conoscermi perché sennò mi conoscono no
funziona ok eccolo qui ce l'abbiamo
fatta perché questa è una figata
guardalo riguarda voli sono uguale cazzo
no raga io dovevo fare il pittore perché
sono troppo bravo da queste sono le
cuffie ragazze sono io questo mi
chiamate che fa dj da rega forza 6 2 in
2 l'anno indovinato è uguale vorrei
anche vedere sono un [ __ ] pittore è
un pre un prete un preservativo
preservativo non è un preser preservi i
ragazzi non so scrivere non lo capiremo
scusate slide cosa vuol dire slide a
slitta con questa sì è una slick ad
assolutamente sì riesco a ragazzi il
nuovo pick up xavi a terzisti avete
assistito in diretta sono troppo
contento ragazzi che siano capaci di
cos'è sta roba patata protetto la gola
go like no canzone lago si sono è una è
una patata blu una patata blu ne pillola
è lo scritto prima io sto a poole bull
se l'ho preso l'ho preso
sono in vantaggio sono i ragazzi di un
punto sto vincendo ma sto vincendo io ho
vinto suo cazzo
ok basta travi ancora questi sono altri
livelli di gioco non c'è bisogno
niente applausi sky budan antenna per
barba faccio la barba prova a disegnare
la barba ragazzi anche se dubito di
riuscire a fare una cosa così la trova
questa faccia e bellissima face sì bravo
però aspetta ho detto aspetta ho detto
aspetta e non deve poi scrivere quello
che cazzo vuoi perché c'è la barbabella
arad e adesso per guardi ho fatto un
autoritratto zio sei uguale perché bravo
bra tra l'altro tanto hai fatto che sei
arrivato ultimo per che c'hai la barba
che sembra il pube di un orso e non si
capì no ma a volte ragazzate li fate dei
disegni che sono qualcosa di pietoso
io faccio pagare ma gesù il tartarughe
ninja
watermelon sarà più o meno si dà e
natura morta proprio questa natura
triste non autore marco si ascolta si sa
se disegni dei peni non è che indovino
di più niente lui disegna dei peni bene
fosse non azzeccata anche la prima porro
leaf clover certo era la mia seconda
scelta dopo penetra torchi al tizio con
la barba quindi stronzo
ho vinto non ho vinto però quasi
minuscola golf golf
cioè ha vinto la ragazza ha vinto lui
però io non lo accetto voglio la
rivincita perché sono mi incazzo
carota canotte grata facciamo carattere
ragazzi non c'è l'arancione quindi devo
andare col rosso per forza liechtstein
sito sono sei una cazzata
non puoi non indovinare adesso lo fanno
vuoi che ti disegni oppure bugs bunny
che se la mangia non lo so te lo faccio
se vuoi a questo questo e bugs bunny
questo è proprio blog danni in tutta la
sua maestosità se starò illumina i no
ragazzi illuminati hanno indovinato
tutti tranne io perché non giustamente
capanna cup under the tenth tenda
tendano ad esso lo scrivo tenda ma devo
fare con la colla la cia ci posso
provare però non solo la dovrei fare
bianca il problema è che è lo sfondo
bianco quindi me la prendo nel deretano
quindi la faccio così
ma di questa questa è proprio una coda
proprio l'idea di essere una cosa cioè
tipo 1 che ho la mano sul muro che il
muro è pieno di colla quindi quando
stacca la mano la colla watt viene via
milano ragazzi hanno indovinato tutto
sono un genio sono un [ __ ] genio
monde week with which si sta vedendo
chiesto zio ed enel e gli schiaffi e
intendente anche se sì certamente quello
è un dente ma sicuro proprio casa fuori
casa fuori
quel quadro quadro quadro picture quadro
bus bus bus le tette
no non è un tetto che lui ha scritto
busta monnalisa monna lisa la monna lisa
facevo prima perfetto esattamente come
quello di leonardo al quale uguale
spiccicato e lui ragazzi ciechi kick pre
a far kick prova questo ecco adesso devo
fare uno che si è preso un calcio nel
culo tipo così dai questo è uscito da
dire
la testa un po meno ok minchia la non
puoi non indovinare questa e cazzo è
uguale my name is billiemme ai covered
by chocolite giulio voilà league mia and
your haga non ce la posso più fare cassa
di latte samurai certamente un samurai
smack my name is billy certo è mai
perché my name is il dentifricio così
charity più tipici non mi ricordo mi
scientifici l'inglese porca [ __ ] di
free cioè to the past tutto affanculo
tutta la fascia lavoro fanno daimi ce
l'avevo fatta da me la ti prego da me la
buona ho paura dice cosa va a disegnare
su tiziano perché si chiama è un dato da
ad einstein stays dai sì ho vinto da the
certo da dado si dice assolutamente da
dei mille chypre ma fareste stereo sera
facciamo uno step lo stereo sono capace
regali si stanno insomma per la spagna
questo è uno stereo zio devi indovinare
che è uno stereo indovina aimi che è uno
step più di così come te lo devo fare
zio questo sto ascoltando ragazzi musica
tunz tunz è bellissima ma lei questa è
veramente un figo
cioè io io vorrei parliamone di questo
capolavoro perché è un capolavoro della
madonna ragazzi bruno mars assolutamente
sì io direi che è una trappola per topi
però non so come si dice in inglese
computer password password sì sì sì sì
l'ho fatta non indovina non indovinano
indovina si sono prima sono prima
ragazzi se la indovino adesso se la
indovino adesso vinto deve riuscire a
farmi dominare su deficiente se riesce a
farmi dominare
1234 numbers numbers e se sì ho vinto ho
visto e l'ho fatto in una maniera 13 a
11 ragazzi o stravinto io che ho fatto
un culo così tizio con la barba perché
la mia barba e più bella d'accordo
ragazzi è stato veramente fi ilove york
grazie zio è stato veramente figo
ragazzi però concludo qui anche perché
gran lonely volete farmi capire che sto
tizio battaglia sud ro man thing
pedofili sud roma i figli non avevo
ancora visti ma adesso ma adesso su
youtube che ragazzi servillo è piaciuto
ma sotto sotto un commento mi piace
anche a pagliari facebook che come nel
video tratto una descrizione se dovessi
di sky ci vediamo al prossimo video
della ragazzi